Speaker 1: All right, so we can say a lot
of different things about Steve Bannon,
former Breitbart propagandist, former Trump
adviser, we can say he's an immoral person. We
can say he's a disgusting individual. We can say
his politics are all wrong and all of those things
would be true. But Steve Bannon is not a stupid
guy when it just comes to basic, fundamental
statements about how elections work, for
example. And that's why I'm not fully getting
why Steve Bannon is continuing to say that
any day now, Donald Trump is going to be back
in the White House. And in fact, on his recent
program, The War Room on Real America's Voice.
Steve Bannon said Trump's going to be back
in 2022 or maybe even before. Now, of course,
Donald Trump is not going to be back as
president in 2022 or maybe even before.
And I know that Steve Bannon knows that. So
why is he saying it? Let's consider that as
we watch this clip, take a look at this.
Speaker 2: The quiet part out loud today.
The anxiety the Hey where are you? The Pearl
clutching? Is the Democratic Party's fear of the
return of Trump. That's why all these committees
are that's what they're trying to do. That's what
this whole the Justice Department is the Senate
that Dick Durbin's got the long face, the return
of Trump, and it ain't going to be in 2024. It's
going to be a 2022 or May, maybe before as we
start the decertification process out in Arizona.
Speaker 1: Let the American, there is no such
process. OK, now I know Steve Bannon doesn't
believe that. He just there's no way he's he's
we can make a lot of criticisms of him, but
he doesn't believe that. So is this the same
as when Steve Scalise won't answer? When Chris
Wallace asks him again and again and again? Was
the election stolen from Trump? And Steve Scalise
answers every question other than the one that's
actually being asked Is it Steve Bannon signaling?
I don't know, because Steve Bannon doesn't need
Trump support to be reelected. For example,
Steve Bannon is not in the same position. So
why is Steve Bannon saying this now as far as
the facts? Remember that there's no mechanism
that makes this possible. There's no, you
know, the line of succession is Joe Biden,
Kamala Harris, Nancy Pelosi. No one is doubting.
I mean, maybe they are, but it's not part of the
story that Nancy Pelosi's election in 2020 was
also fraudulent. Nancy Pelosi is duly elected.
So if by some unknown means that we don't even
know you get the presidential election thrown out,
Nancy Pelosi becomes president. It's not Donald
Trump. The Supreme Court will not be reinstating
Donald Trump. No one will be reinstating
Donald Trump. I know Steve Bannon knows
this horrible person, but he's not this stupid.
So why is he saying it? Maybe he wants clicks
and this gets him clicks. I don't know. Maybe
it's a signal to people to prepare for another
violent coup attempt. Neither is a great scenario.
I think the coup is worse from those two options.
Simply trying to monetize a dumb audience is one
thing, but trying to weaponize that audience into
attempting another riot, I think is far worse.
Quite frankly, it's not like there have really
been major consequences, at least yet for the
rioters. So why wouldn't you go for another
coup attempt if Steve Bannon tells you that
maybe it'll work? Also on decertifying Arizona.
Whenever you run out of ideas or your
ideas are totally rejected by reality,
what they do is they come up with a new word
that people don't yet know much about, so they
think maybe that could happen. The new word is
decertification of Arizona will never happen.
It's not a thing. And remember that even if it
did, even if decertifying the Arizona results
of the 2020 election in what is almost 2022
now, even if they came up with a way to do it.
Flipping Arizona from Trump to Biden doesn't
change who won in 2020 anyway. Arizona's 11
electoral votes Joe Biden had 306. You need 270 to
win without Arizona. Biden still has 295. So it's
a layer of nonsense upon layer of nonsense and
people fall for it and whether the point is money.
Or it's to prepare people to get violent
again the next time that this doesn't happen,
or it's because Steve Bannon believes he has
to do this because it'll help him in some way.
Curry favor with Donald Trump, which maybe
he still needs for some reason, I don't know.
Whatever the reason, people fall for this stuff
and it's extraordinarily dangerous, and it
doesn't seem like it's going to stop any time soon